che cazzo dovevo fare invito tutti i
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono pari j
oggi sono volgare allo ragazzi vedere se
riusciamo a fare qualcosa di decente
suoi primis almeno oggi perché new poco
jump partiamo così alla riscossa
cos'è cos'è mi sembra di toccare un pene
flaccido dio santo sentite no no aspetti
capiamo un attimo ho sempre detto io che
con questo deve essere hard ma non è
duro per niente c'è più flaccido quello
degli altri mi sono ridotto a fare
livelli di f bis dove devo scavalcare
dei peni pronti incazzare zio che va
bene uguale per il pane duro
sì sì sì perché la forza del bene sempre
nei nostri cuori perfetto ragazzi ci
siamo alla madonna e tutto flaccido il
suo cazzo di livello e pique don o un
livello di dei miei [ __ ] ecco bello
bello visto che si va da zio meglio di
matrix e ragazzi e sono durato di più
prima quando sono stato fermo cioè di
spiegato ma [ __ ] il mio pene mi
serviva il bene sì c'è alla testa mi
fate vincere la testa no josè è un nuovo
tipo di fiom da ragazzi ragazzo me lo
sento che ci ha posto perfetto e fin qua
e qualora non ha preso 6
ecc ecc perché quando un salto lo fai
col culo all'aria vinci sempre
ma michele dotti che stava andando tutti
plain crash
non so perché cieli schianterà ancora ma
basta ascoltati a no no il sedile il
sedile migliorato anche preso i posti in
prima classe lui da [ __ ] perché ho
vinto senza sapere chi sia e vai sentiva
affanculo cioè di no no no no no non è
il momento di inglobarsi e ragazzi fate
con calma con col ho schivato l'offesa
se un bel giorno quando scrivi degli
obesi che ti arrivano addosso vero
ragazzi altro mi sto tenendo non mi sto
tenendo sto scherzando e dai vai lì hoc
ma york ho vinto sono uscita mi son
riuscito a rimanere dentro l'aereo fino
alla fine beh perché un vero capitano
non abbandona mai il suo aereo con la
sua nave o la sua moglie ma a meno che
la moglie non se ne vada con sedile
quello in tutto un altro paio di maniche
salto della fede no fermi ragazzi fermi
la tutto giusto fare un secondo allora
sembra clapis quando si stava per
suicidarsi cioè bellissimo allora non è
non è più il salto della fede ma è il se
il salto di fede proprio federico bravo
fede ballo ragazzi proviamo salto della
fede anche se non sa che bello devo
salvare come faccio a sapere mi è finito
un braccio in gola ma forte seria perché
ho vinto ma al gel peak è il più buffi è
diverso dall'altro votava la 1a giornata
ci aveva bisogno di aggiornamento è
ascoltami porcospino con le guance rosse
tra i tori cd pizza
quella è una pizza spiegami come fa a
essere una pizza se siamo sul fondo
dell'oceano zio come cazzola
avete mai assaggiato la pizza col
porcospino non perché vi assicuro che
buona 99 per cento
questo quell'adrenalina volevo oggi
maledizione che gioco di merda
bene ci siamo che aveva in casa i falsi
spezzato tutto l'osso del collo zio però
va bene vinti david hare di tlc ancora
dai basta con queste cose di bryce manco
fossi già si sentì e non sapevo che john
cena fosse un feticista perché li stanno
usando i piegate facendo yoga fratelli
da ditemelo perché sembra che gli
puzzano i piedi talmente tanto che non
si allontanano lo sto capendo e
ringrazia che rompersi non è stato il
tuo collo jazz cook it raw cookie
trovano cannock adesso non ci sono più
boltro ci sono i cookie trovo ci manca
quel kick ass
la chance el pais dovrebbe essere una
versione di più di pai coi capelli grigi
che carino
cioè un livello dove dai da mangiare a
più di pace cioè fammi capire puzza ma
con cazzo mangi tu io questa roba qua la
faccio che miei amici ogni tanto perché
dobbiamo fare i [ __ ] quando siamo al
ristorante 1 si lancia il chicco 2
l'altro marco fosse gigi buffon in pro
miglia in april wilbur ross in due abiti
ricchi abitri kids io pensi che pensi di
forte ma poi del fatto che il rock swing
e l'ha fatto probabilmente un interista
per ovvi motivi anche uno juventino è
anche un milanista sta scherzando è un
multi squadra ragazzi proviamoci che sia
di più assi squadra sia fotte sega tanto
non segue carlo non seguo il cazzo non
segue perché dovete farmi odiare i rock
swing che sono così tanto tranquilli
bravo dai le botte soccorre ma guarda
viaggi ci sono che c'è lo schermo rosso
perché rispondono mettiamo cristiano
ronaldo che batte rigori tanto manca
solo quello che bello ragazzi la mia
vita è completa massaggio alla pancia e
cristiano ronaldo nello sfondo
fantastico perfetto per cristiano che
gol che gol lo fanno alla fatto è dei
ragazzi la partita è sua
uomo partita cosa cazzo già scritto ciao
frate che cazzo è una versione di shrek
blu ama sei stronzo
no ragazzi è uno è uno stress richiesto
è successo mi son dato il cinque con la
mia stessa mano a caso
ciao ragazzi qualcuno che abbiamo è che
cazzo non aveva preso con una palla da
tennis possible ever grazie guardando
mancano minacce volo scritto mina su
lamina grazie quale credevo fosse una
specie di forno a microonde moderno se
la doveva arrivare io il mio obiettivo è
la mina fantastico è andata malissimo
come primo tentativo credo che non
riuscirò mai nella vita
era proprio una mina quella lì ci avevo
ragione non so come ho fatto ad avere
questi incredibili intuizioni dai veloce
dai ci credono più le braccia così non
ci voglio credere
no ragazzi oggi oggi è così oggi devo
incassare ma non è possibile dai
maledizione ma si è fatta
fermi no aspetta per ferno fermo che
staranno controlla piano fermo mi stavo
amore ragazzi stavo morendo
vi dico solo questo stava bene john cena
smackdown e mi mancava questa ovviamente
parti con un cannone perché john cena
ciao sera adesso state tutti aspettando
che io metterei a intro di john cena ma
non la metterò perché sommato us
e con totò padre sandra sword trocar non
devo lanciare il parma va mica c'è
quest'uomo è iron man resiste alle spade
lancia due volte questo è il livello
come infilzare di c'è una roba sobria
che chi più si mettiamo oggetti chi se
ne fotte bravo bravo
niente ho alle spalle non cercasse
flying balls spyphone rainbow babbo
natale subito reti uk and the first già
anzio e sai con chi stai parlando
voglio far capire con babbo ad un
ragazzino con babbo natale sono riuscito
con babbo natale a fare un livello così
basta proprio la vita grazie grazie
grazie a tutti grazie sono ha gasato
predefinito un livello di è più questa è
la mia vita
rato placido che cazzo di nome perché
c'è un m la sua no non ci giuro che
sembra più geometri nasce realistico
bello frate di grafica c'è manca tutto
il resto problema e quello pro vabbè
vabbè dai pensa pensavo peggio
effettivamente va bene così va bene così
mai forza così facile a questi livelli e
ragazze da prezzo la nuova bene c'è
anche la supposto reja è diventato
subito il mio uno dei miei preferiti in
assoluto fantastico normale perfetto
cosa che c'è scritto trattato nato un
non so che cosa sia ma io sto coprendo
un gatto imbalsamato
eppure incazzato a cura delle
spiegazioni vi prego solo per le
leggende certo perché sono storie che lo
possa cioè mi ci arrivo ma [ __ ]
dai steve mickey è impossibile non fermi
sarò ma mi ha preso troppo ma veramente
una foto utilità cos'è che cazzo fai
no no no no ma non ci voglio non ci
credo mai sim assetto e attacchi a
qualcosa con le mani si suppone che le
tue braccia ci rimangono attaccate sono
che cazzo serve spiega il 100 un po di
osteoporosi zio c'è nel senso proprio
non sai tenere ok che un pene di gomma
non si sa è che suo zio sui lardo minali
stronzo ma sei serio
grazie a tutti grazie a tutti i ragazzi
però poi ottimi livelli al solito vj
boltro fabi geni e le droghe ciò fa vip
rossi sì proprio quel nostro ok
spiegarmi che cosa c'entrano le droghe
non hai ragione ci sono proprio tante
droghe vince ci ho provato
non so che cosa cazzo il combinato
guarda zio ho paura allora scott ap se
non sai fare livelli di è qui non li
faccia vabbè che bello mi piace questo
livello qua come guarda come dondolo
guardano a metano come steve fa vj
versus isis usate il padre con il figlio
per questo livello sono finiti e
bombardate leasys non ci riesci primi z
alla fine che ti aiuta buona fortuna se
vince al primo tentativo urla allah
akhbar zio al akhbar ma non si scrive il
costituto che succede se scrivo su
google al akhbar come l'ha scritto lui o
akbar
che cosa c'entra perché quando uno vede
un bacio troppo sto c nato dovrebbe
andar lì e fare due ragazzi e arriva
alla fine nel caso non riesco a finire
per aiutarmi al akhbar scritto così e ci
mancherebbe altro ma [ __ ] guarda
amico mio mi è stato molto d'aiuto l'arx
iannucci bolzano me l'avessi detto sai e
qui a quest'ora ragazzi importante
ce l'ho fatta va bene i ragazzi concluso
che l'episodio mi piace meritato solo
per il fatto che questo livello non si è
capito gli in questo episodio non si è
capito un cazzo ma di niente proprio
ragazzi scrivete che ci vediamo al
seguito è bello ragazzi che è tornato a
funzionare il telecomando grazie a dio
beh ragazzi